foreign
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
today we'll be learning complete HTML
and CSS before we begin I would like to
inform you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple Technologies so do
subscribe to our channel to never miss
out on an update let's discuss the
agenda for this tutorial we'll start
with discussing HTML in 10 minutes let
me move forward to discuss HTML classes
and IDs drop down in HTML content boxes
in HTML how to create Ms slider and
navigation bar in HTML and how to create
HTML registration form after grasping
all the essential theoretical Concepts
we'll design a full stated web page
using the concepts that you learned
above we'll go through some of the
important interview questions in HTML
and discuss some skills that will help
you become a front-end web developer
we'll end the session with web
development roadmap
now what exactly is the basic web
architecture now web architecture is
made up of three essential elements
that's the website that is the front end
of a web application that is visible to
the user then there is the server which
constitutes the back end of a web
application and holds and manages all
the data and finally there's the IP
address that is the address assigned to
a website in order to be accessible on
the internet
first up let's have a look at what
website is so your browser starts by
loading the main HTML file and then the
CSS and JavaScript
the user interacts with the website and
is not concerned with the backend of an
application now secondly we have the
server once you've developed your
website you'll have to host it on your
server to make it accessible on the
internet
server along with the database contains
all the data of a website and
facilitates user interaction
lastly this IP address which is the
third element of the web architecture
now website is hosted on an IP address
we put a domain name over that IP
address the same way we put names over
people's phone numbers
when you type a domain name in the
browser it will give you the server call
the server will then send over the
website to you
next what is HTML HTML is the most
widely used markup language for
developing and structuring web pages on
the internet
it defines the structure of websites and
formats these web pages
so what exactly is CSS then
now CSS is a simple design language used
for making web pages look more beautiful
and presentable
it can be attached to any HTML element
to style it or even position it
according to the developer's choice
then you must be wondering what exactly
is Javascript
now JavaScript is a powerful interpreted
language targeted for web development it
is used for making web pages interactive
and bringing the web pages to life
so now let's create your first website
now HTML short for hypertext markup
language is the coding standard for
documents designed for web browsers
consisting of a series of elements or
tags and which can be used to structure
a web page right so these elements can
include headings paragraphs div
containers tables and more HTML tags are
nested meaning there are opening and
closing tags with the content in between
those tags so now let's write a simple
HTML code that will help you understand
the basics of the language so for this I
am using the text editor that is Visual
Studio code you can go ahead and
download this text editor from their
official website so here I've created a
simple dot HTML file in my vs code and
I've added the initial HTML files
now let me explain to you one by one
now doctype is not so much of a tag but
it is more of an instruction now this
indicates the browser that the document
type to be served to the user is in fact
an HTML document
now this doctype instruction should
always be included at the very top of
your HTML page next up you have the HTML
tag that is used to contain all the web
pages HTML code right so it contains an
opening and closing tag with contents in
between them
the HTML tag can also have attributes
now for example there's the Lang
attribute allowing you to specify the
spoken language of the contents of the
page followed by the HTML tag there's
the head tag now this is the first
section of the code that contains all of
the information about the web pages
properties links and more it could have
Pages title description additional meta
tags and CSS code so here I've used the
title tag and let's give a title say
HTML
in 10 minutes
[Music]
all right you can also add CSS to the
Head tag by using the style tag and
change the display styles of HTML
elements that are being used the next
section is the body tag now the body tag
contains all the displayable contents of
your web page including headings
paragraphs div containers tables and
more
now the HTML header tags are used to add
headings to a web page there are several
types of headings available for
developers to add to a web page right so
first off let's have a look at them I'm
going to create a simple H1 heading tag
and the message I'm displaying is this
is
the first heading
all right
after this I'm going to add a paragraph
tag which creates padding in the top and
bottom of the element to help separate
the text between each paragraph
right so I'm gonna add a P tag and Save
this is the paragraph tag
foreign
tag and say this is the second heading
now you can also add line breaks which
are helpful from time to time if you
want to provide a single line break in
your content you can do so by adding the
BR tag so here let me just add one for
better understanding
now the HTML div tag defines a division
or a section in an HTML document that is
used as a container for other HTML
elements now these elements can include
content areas sidebars page bars page
headers Footers Etc
this tag is used to apply styles to HTML
elements that cannot be added otherwise
you can also make use of the HTML image
tag to add images to a web page now
these images in a web page are a very
common site and they can make the
website look more attractive so for that
we can use the image tag so say IMG
within which I mentioned the source
foreign
[Music]
logo so let me just mention that here
and then I'm going to provide width for
it and then a specific height
all right so when you save the file and
when you look at the browser
you can see that uh the first heading is
displayed then your paragraph tag is
displayed followed by the second heading
and then the image now let me show you
how you can add styles for some of these
uh headings and paragraph tags so here
in back in my first heading tag let me
just say styles
and let me change the font
of the content that is being displayed
I'm going to change it to Career new
and for my paragraph tag let me display
the content in italics so I'll say font
style and make it italics
so let me save this and when I look at
the browser
you can see that the font has changed
and so has the font style here
so now we've covered a few important
HTML tags used to develop a web page now
there are many other tags available for
almost everything you'd want to add to a
web page now all of these are available
on the internet for you and you can use
them in your website in this tutorial
we are going to learn about the classes
and ID in the HTML and how to use them
so without further Ado let's get started
so what is an HTML Cloud an HTML class
attribute is used to specify a single or
multiple class names for an HTML element
the class name can be used by CSS and
JavaScript to do some tasks for HTML
elements
you can also use this class in the CSS
with a specific class with a period
character followed by the name of the
class first selecting elements
so let's jump onto the demo to
understand the classes and ID better so
we are on a Sublime Text Trader
let's add the standard boilerplate of
HTML
we'll give the title as
classes
and ID in HTML
let's start with the basic example
we'll see how to define an HTML class so
inside the body tag
will add one H1
and will give this
a class name of
head1
we'll add some text here this is the
heading one
now you can copy this part because we'll
need it enough for the lines
so for the H2
this will be the heading 2
for H3
this will be heading 3.
and let's add one more H4
this is the heading 4.
so as you can see we have used the same
class name in all our H1 H2 S3 and H4
so if you save the file and
go to the page and refresh
you'll see the headings are there on the
page this is the heading one heading to
heading 3 and heading 4.
now let's learn how we can use this
class name for our starting purpose
so we'll open the style tag here
and you will mention the class Name by
period followed by the class name so
head one
open the parenthesis
and let's set the color to
light sand
and we'll set the font family to set to
it cursive
keep the background color to Black
okay so you can see we have mentioned
the class name dot head one for our
styling purposes and we have given the
color Point family and background color
for it so just save the file and go back
refresh
now you can see we have designed this H1
H2 H3 and H4 using a class tag
now let's use another example with a
different clock name
so
here only will make the changes let's
name this class as H2 this H3 and let it
be H4
now you can style them separately for
the head to
we can set the color
to say like
pink and we can set the font background
color to
red okay
now
similarly for the H3
Dot
head 3 set the color to
I don't know what color this is let's
say kuchisa
and set the background color to let's
say blue
okay save the file and go back to the
page
now you can see we have designed our H1
H2 H3 and H4 using the different class
name
here is the example of using the
multiple classes on the same course
now one thing you should note that these
class name must be separated by the
space
there are few points you should know
while working with the class so the
first one will be the class attribute
can be used on any HTML element
like any HTML element can have a class
name the second point will be the class
name is a case sensitive
head one
and if we change here to say
we keep this Edge as cap capital so this
will be long the style won't be
implemented on the page now if you
refresh you can see the style is not
implemented
so the class names are case sensitive
let's change this back
refresh and now you can see our design
is back
so this was all about HTML classes now
let's move on to the idea attribute
so the HTML ID attribute is used to
specify the unique ID for an element of
the HTML document
it allocates the unique identifier which
is used by the CSS and a JavaScript for
performing certain tasks
in cascading stylesheet that is CSS we
mentioned an element with a specific ID
by using the hash symbol followed by the
ID
let's work on an example to understand
this better
so we'll use the same previous example
we'll mention the H1 and this time we'll
use the ID
so ID and we'll name it as head one
this is the first heading
for H2 also we will mention the ID name
as head 1 only
head one
this is the
second heading
now to style The Heading we'll go back
here will open the style tag
and we'll use the hash chamber to
mention the ID so hash
head one open the parenthesis
we'll set the color to
light green
you'll set the font family to cursive
and we'll set the background color
to Black
okay now save the file and go back and
refresh
so you can see this works a similar
manner to the class apart from it that
we use the hash symbol to mention the ID
name
so now let's change the example and use
the different ID name for different
hedge funds
so this can be H1 this can be H2
let's add one more we'll name it as ID
okay
so we'll style the
head to
will set the color to red
for head 3
will set the color to Yellow
let's use green yellow okay save the
file
go back and refresh
now you can see we have the different
style for different IDs so in this way
you can use the different IDs to design
your HTML page in this tutorial we are
going to learn how you can create a drop
down in your nav bars using this HTML
and CSS so we are more Sublime Text
Editor I have the dot HTML and Dot CSS
file ready so let's start by adding the
standard boilerplate
let's give it a title
link your CSS file to the HTML file
now inside the body I'll add the ul's
we have added this hash so that when you
click on this home button it won't
redirect you to anywhere
so just save the file
and we'll go back to our page
so you can see we have this home here
okay so let's add some more
so just copy paste this
and we'll name this section about
okay
now inside this about I'll require some
sub menus
so inside this I'll open another UL tag
we'll add sections such as team
clients
career and Legacy
and we'll close the LI tag here
okay now save the file and go back here
and refresh
now we'll add some more so here
we'll add the Ally for contact
okay so inside this contact I'll add the
submenus
so you will
and I'll copy this code and I'll edit it
here
okay so inside the contacts I'll need
email
phone
that's it
Twitter
and this will be my LinkedIn
okay
now we'll add some more sections
name the services
and this one will be my news
okay
so this looks fine limit of alignment
yeah
so you can see we have this home about
contact services and news and inside
this we have the sub menus
okay we forget to add here
hash inside trips
just mention hash
everywhere
okay save the file
go back and refresh okay
so you can see we have this HTML ready
now let's go back to the CSS and design
these drop downs
so first inside our HTML
so select the body tag
will add one background image so just
the background looks uh more attractive
so I have an image file saved so I'll
jpg so save
go back and refresh
yeah you can see we have this black
thing uh we'll shrink this image
so we will keep the background size to
cover
and we'll keep the font family to aerial
okay
so for the UL tag
we'll keep the margin to zero
we'll keep the padding to zero as well
and we'll set the list style to none
okay now we'll design the URL Li part
so we'll keep the flow to left
width will set to 200 pixels
we will set the height to say 40 pixels
um we'll keep the background color
to something darker say w
ow gray okay
keep the opacity to 0.9
line height 40 pixels
keep the text aligned
to Center
and font size two
20 pixels
save the file go back and refresh
okay you see we have the background
image in the place we have this snap bar
in the place and all the drop downs are
here
okay
now it's time to design UL
Li and a
so for this we'll keep the text
decoration to none
color let's keep white
and we'll set the display to block
save the file and go back
now we'll add the horror effects for
this drop downs okay
so
UL Li
e
a DOT forward
will keep the background color for the
forward to say
foreign
let's see how it looks on the page
refresh
yeah it's look good
now the final part of this requires this
to shrink inside just when you hover
over this so the drop downs will appear
okay
so we'll set this you will Ally
Li 2
display none
and we'll add the whole effect over Li
so that when we hover the drop down
appears
save
go back and refresh now you can see all
the drop downs are inside this
and hover over it on the drop downs
appear
okay so this is all about the drop downs
menu in HTML as we saw that we can
create the beautiful drop downs just by
using the HTML and CSL nothing fancy
in this video we are going to create the
content boxes which are used in web
pages for various purposes
so let's see an example of what we are
going to create so in this video we are
going to create something like this this
is the content box with the icon and the
description of the content box
icons here used is from the font awesome
CDN
so let's start creating
so I have my two files open which is
HTML and CSS
let's add the standard boilerplate
we'll add the content
boxes in HTML
as the title
let's link our CSS file
now inside the body let's add a div
clock container
inside that is class container I'll
create another div box
I will require three such boxes so we'll
copy paste this three times
on the style sheet
let's set the margin
to 0 and padding also to zero
we'll set the font family
to
Sans serif
now
for the container class
will set the position to relative
and will set the width to 200 pixels
it will be the whole width of the
content box
we'll set the height to 300 pixels
and we'll set the margin
to
240 pixels and Auto
for the boxes inside the container
will add the position
relative
and will set the width to
let me explain what this is
this CSS type function is used to
perform a calculation to be used as a
property value
this is specifically used for the width
of the div classes
it requires a mathematical expression
the result will be used as a value
so we'll be using lot of this type
function here in this code
we will set the height to
300 pixels minus 30 pixels
one property of cat function is that it
takes single expression as its parameter
the expression can be any simple
expression combining the following
operators
plus sub that is addition minus that is
subtraction multiplication and division
we'll set the background
to Hash zero zero zero
we'll set it to float left
and we'll specify the margin to 15
pixels
and we'll set the box size into border
box
overflow will be hidden
and Border radius
let's set it to 10 pixels
just save the file and let's go back to
the page to see how it currently looks
so you can see our boxes are in the
proper places we have the background
black with the proper margin between
them okay so we have the structure
let's code more
now we need the icon for that
will require a icon from the font
awesome CDN so we'll add the font
awesome CDM to our page
so we'll search font awesome CDN 4.7.0
we are using the older version because
it is more stable
so go to this font awesome libraries
here select the version and copy the
link tag
go back to the page and add it here
delete this Integrity part
now
here inside this class box
add one div which will be named class
icon
and inside here we'll add the link of
the icon so search here
font or some icon 4.7
go to the first one
here you can search the any icon you
want let me search for
the
information
so I'll go to the information
and I'll copy this
go back to the code and add it here
now inside this I'll create another div
it will be for use for content
so we'll name it class content
and inside this I'll add one S3
info
and inside it
I'll add some
text uh copy this much from here
to there
and delete this whole part
and put it inside
so inside the P tag
add them yeah
so let's go back to the file and see how
it looks right now
okay so you cannot see the icon here
because it is black let's try to change
the color here
so that you can see the icon
so let's set it to ff0
okay so you can see I have the icon in
place this is and this is the text that
we have added to this content box
now let's style this content box first
set it back to zero zero zero
now
container dot box
dot icon
will set the position to Absolute
set the top
to zero
left to zero
and we'll set the width to 100 percent
will set the height also to 100 percent
background will be hash f0000
will set the transition
to 0.5 seconds
and we'll keep the Z index as 1 so that
the icon will be visible
okay
refresh yeah you can see the icon here
now let's add the whole effect on that
so container Dot
box dot over
icon
will set that top to 20 pixels
and calculate the left to
50 minus 40 pixels
with 80 pixels
height keep it to 80 pixels as well
and let's set the Border radius
okay
so now that we have repeat
so now that we have added the hover
effect let's save and go back to the
page
now let's design the icon so container
Dot
box dot icon
dot f a
also set the position to Absolute
top 350 percent
left 50 percent
transform let's translate it to
minus 50 percent
and keep the font size to
80 pixels
transition 0.5 seconds
and we'll set the color to
sure
save the file and let's go back to the
page
yeah so you can see our icon has now
bigger size and with the hover effect it
shrinks for text to be visible
okay
now we need to add the hover effect to
the icon so that the font size increases
for that we'll add container
box dot over
and we'll keep the font size to
40 pixels
okay
now it's time to design the content
inside the container box so we'll set
container
dot box
dot content
all the positions are absolute
will set the top 200 percent
so that run the icon shrinks the whole
text will be visible to the text box
we'll set the height
2 will calculate it
minus 100 pixels
text align Center
keep the padding to 20 pixels
for proper spacing
box sizing as border box
transition to 0 0.5 seconds
and we'll keep the opacity to zero
save the file and let's go back
yeah and you can see the icons are in
the center of the shrinking Circle
now let's add the hover effect
now when you set the opacity to one
another text
okay we are not designed yet S3 and P so
let's start designing it
so container
dot box
dot content H3
indexes
keep the padding to zero
color
and let's keep the font size to 24
pixels
now you will see the text will be
visible Inside the Box
so refresh
yeah you can see this is the heading of
our this content box info
now similarly let's dial the paragraph
tag
so container
dot box
dot content
e
margin will be zero
padding will be also zero
and color will be FFF as usual
if
yup we are almost there
now we will Design these two boxes with
some scraping and effects over here
now
uh inside this
delete them we'll copy paste the above
code here
so copy from here depth class container
we'll change the icon classes here so
for this let's keep search as in rch
instead of copying the class by going
back to the font ctm it will directly
add the class search here it will know
the name of the class
and here we can add
location
so the class name for location is map
marker
save the file
and let's go back
yeah now you can see
these things are here it's a good
content box when you hover over this box
so
this whole thing shrinks and you can see
the text visible
now add We'll add some Styles will
change the color and we'll add one
background here so that when this
shrinks the background color of the
black changes
okay
so we'll go back to our code
so to change the color of the box
you will add here dot container
dot box
and we'll use the nth child property the
nth child
one because the first box
dot icon
so we'll keep its background too
think
okay
and Dot container
box and child
one its color will be when it shrinks
let's keep it to Orange
yeah
so save the file
go back
and refresh
okay so you can see we have the icons in
places and when you go
click on here set the hover effect
shrinks this and this is the printing
color we have the background orange with
some text here
you can see
smooth transitions
so this is all for the content boxes in
HTML you can use different icons here
using this font as awesome icon there
are several icons here you can use any
of them and just make sure that the
padding and the text are aligned in the
proper places in this video we'll learn
how you can create a beautiful HTML
Stander for using just HTML and CSS of
JavaScript
something like this you have the
background image and this images that I
have taken for example purpose we have
this video button and you click on the
radio buttons we can go through our
images one by one
also the images will change
automatically after sometimes as you can
see
so let's see how you can create this in
a slider
so here in the desktop I have created
one file where I have the required
images
and HTML and CSS file
so first investment file let's add our
radio buttons
so recruitment div
idend class slider
inside this
which will name the big class slides
inside this flashlight will add the
radio buttons so in product
the input type will be radio
and let's give this name
radio button
and we'll tag them with ID radio 1.
so as you can see
during potential so we'll add three
review buttons here
so just copy paste this four times
here use the ID to Radio 2 review and
video code so we can distance between
the four radio buttons
you know
so after the creative returns we'll add
our required images so we'll create
another div and limit class
slide first
inside I'll create an image tag
and special part of dimension
in a similar we create a few div tags
for four images
so just we'll do certainly another term
with class name
slide
inside this image
2.jpg
foreign
images
so let's just fix this images in the CSS
will add the body
and we'll set the margin to zero pixels
adding to zero
we'll set the height to say 100 vertical
height
will set the display to select
uh we'll justify the content to Center
we'll set the Align items to Center
and we set the background to Black
so just
refresh this file
so it's time to fix these images
so just
set the slider bit to
800 pixels
there's an L we'll say this
at the height to 500 pixels
they said the Border radius
to 10 pixels
and overflow will keep as hidden
for the slice part
we'll set the width to 500 percent
height to 500 pixels
and displayed to select
let's change the file and see how it
looks on the page
so yeah you can see the images now in a
proper size you have to produce video
button we have the background black
so let's fix this hints
so for the slide input
navigation button
so after this
has another day
the class name
navigation Auto let's see
and inside this navigation Auto will add
Dev
class
or to button one
we need the full button so we'll copy it
four times
and this will be my button true
this will be button free and this will
be button 4.
outside this they will create another
navigation button so we'll name this
navigation
make sure it's published right now we
education
manual
and inside this
book we'll add our radio buttons which
will be manual
the limit class manual button m-e-m-e
we need the code button so we'll copy it
four times
we change the label to Radio 2
radium 3 and radio 4.
so I think this will work enough so here
we have the navigation
okay we have a spelling mistake here
the class and navigation class here
so let's recheck our code
it's a good pattern to each of the code
so that you don't encounter any error so
okay we have a little class slider here
images
additive tags with the name slide
okay we have created a navigation Auto
the code buttons and navigation manual
the four buttons okay
so let's see if the file and go back and
refresh it and see how it looks
okay
we have add some CSS here
so inside the slides
input
filter display tool done
for the dot slide will vector
with 20 percent
and we'll set the transition to two
seconds
now we'll
add this type or image
will set the width to 800 pixels
and we'll set the height to State 500
pictures
okay
let's save the file and let's go back to
see how it looks right now
foreign
s are properly aligned here
we have to style our radio buttons for
here so let's go back to our CFS
now the code we are going to write here
maybe for the manual slide navigation
so just add here comment manual slide
navigation
so
let me remember the code
yeah
so we'll add the first
class navigation manual
will set the position to Absolute
instead of it to 800 pixels
will not have a height here will set the
margin
to the margin top will be minus 40
degrees
and this we will keep it as black
and the justify content
will be sent out
so let's do a and go back to the page
see how it looks right now
okay the images are in the center you
can see
now you cannot see your radio buttons
just as now we have to add some color to
it so that the reader buttons to be
visible
so go back to our CSS
and add the language button
we'll set the Border
to set C pick files
solid and red
you can take any color you want
we'll set the padding to 5 pixels
uh we'll set the Border radius to say 9
pixels
we set the cursor to point pointer so
that whenever buttons the cursorbit has
a pointer
and we'll set the transition to one
seconds
say
go back and refresh
so now you can see the buttons are here
not properly spaced but yeah
so let's add the spacing and everything
else
so we'll take the manual button
will set the margin
right protocol tools
and it's time to add the whole effect so
for the manual
button
now mobile will be
um say background
in the color
blue
so just save the file and go back and
refresh
yeah so you can see our manual buttons
are in place
when you hover over it you can see the
blue effects and when you click
nothing happens right now because we
don't have in JavaScript response to
this data button We'll add them in the
end
first let's design these buttons so this
has for the manual button
now we'll add one code which will be
used when you want to set up the radio
button by default
so let's understand how this video
buttons work in this
files where two or no options to
identify which are usually exclusive and
the user has to evacue one first in
other words
any of the button that is selected on
the list previously
moments
so we'll add hash video
dot check
so to find that we have added here is
more sibling combinator
it combines two sequence as simple
collectors having a field parent and the
second must come immediately after the
first
so we'll add DOT first
and for this we set the margin left
to zero
okay so this will be radio one
the label that we added in our manual
buttons
we need four such
button so we'll copy this four times one
one two three and four
this will be my quality button
and we'll set the margin left here to
minus 20 pixels
or redo button 3 will set it to say
minus 40 pixels
and for the last button we'll set it to
minus 15 pixels
navigation button now let's design for
automatic navigation button
so we open Dot navigation
we'll set the position to Absolute
then set the display to select
we will set the upgrade
to 800 pixels
let's justify the content to the center
and put the margin top
60 pixels
now it's so I'll add the file to
navigation or Twitter
so
then set the Border
to same model that we have used here
it will say pixel solid red
make sure you keep this see if it's a
solid and same in both the navigation
Auto and navigation manual because if
you change the color here you will see
the two manual buttons there so for this
example let's change this to Green
so when you save and go back
and refresh
yeah
you can see the two buttons here this is
the green and this is red so there are
two colors the group of buttons will
overlap will not feel good so we just
keep it here red
and set the padding to type it first
yeah
this is for the Border radius to nine
pixels
and we'll set the transition to one
seconds
okay
now same code AS here which I've added
for checking of the video buttons
so we'll just copy this whole code
and paste it here
we'll have to tweak from pin will
so the class was navigation dot Auto
so we'll add here
navigation approve
Dot Auto button one
will set here some background
so we'll delete this code
um
background let's say
angle think
copy this code Ctrl C
delete this whole thing control View
and just change the radio button there
this will be radio button
foreign
place
now we are already designing in place
let's go back to the code and refresh
so now everything is great the
background is that that the images is
properly aligned we have this button so
let's click
so when you click you see the images
slides this is a photo match
okay
second
and first so if it is ready all that now
is left is to add the JavaScript code to
this image character function in
automatic manner
so now we'll go back to this HTML file
and below this ZIP tab
and open once click tab
inside the script tag
we create one
variable name counter
will set it to one open we create one
function set interval
foreign
thank you
so what we thought specifically does is
we have created one variable named
counter and it will check against the ID
that we have created a radio then the
radio button is checked and it
encounters
the counter will be plus plus that order
will increase by one
so after the counter has reached to flow
so it will get back to the starting
point that is one so
the whole point of this code is to
make the images slide in in a blue so
that's same
and go back
now when you refresh
you see the images we move after
sometimes
specifically two seconds
now when the images become last page it
goes back to the first
it also changes
manually when we talk about external
based development so in HTML based
development navigation is very important
where you have called multiple Pages
attached to so that when you click on
this page or click on any hyperlink it
will take you to the new page now so
that you can move back and forth so this
navigation is very essential part of any
web development so that you can offer
the navigation so this simple
application of HTML we would like to
start from scratch so let's go and
create a new folder now and give the
name called navigation
and inside this navigation we want to
create some new pages so
here I'm going to create index
dot HTML
the CSS name will be app dot CSS and
along with this we would like to also
create some new folder inside this I'll
keep all the navigation files inside
this so I can save pages
in such a species let me have total
number of three pages with me one is
called about
dot HTML
then we create
contact
dot HTML
then we create one more that is called
Services dot HTML
dot HTML
so these three links we will create it
one by one but first let's start with
the index.ht
so what's there in my index.html file so
first thing I would like to start with
my same HTML syntax here
well this is my basic construct
so I will start with my link Ariel from
here so that I can have my Starship with
me link audio equal to style sheet hrf
equal to app Dot CSL go I have not
written anything but I just left it as a
blank
in my body tag I would start with the
navigation so HTML5 brought you some new
tags nodes call a nav tag which is once
again
won't change anything drastically in
your browser however they are called
cementex which will help you for the SEO
that stands for search engine
optimization so I'll start with my nav
inside my nap I will start with my div
I'll say navigation bar so but before
that I say
class equal to
heading
this is my Dev tag and inside my tip tag
I want to bring my heading so I say H4
and I said
navigation bar and after the div tag I
will start with my URL tag which is the
unordered list inside my
on audit list I can set a like that sent
for list items and I can offer not many
links inside this so you will I just
offer the class
equal to
nav hyphen
and inside this is my Android tag I said
8 which is the anchor tag
so
a link href equal to
now here I offer
the name I say index
table and that's it and this will be by
default active so we say plus equal to
active
okay
class equal to it active and H are equal
to index.html file and here we are from
home
for home page I'll copy this line
and paste it for other three urls
so
here
the active won't be there instead we say
HTTP code to
the location called pages
onto these pages
so we say about
dot HTML and here we say about
okay copy this
paste it
and all of this about we always say
for SS dot HTML and here we say
services
insert this you offer
contact
okay and once the lab tag is over
I will offer the tip
div class
equal to just give the name 40 hyphen
text
I just say H1 tag inside this
is the home page
that's it so that's my home page which
is ready with me
and along with this whichever the other
pages are also available
those pages I also want to use
so first of all let me check how this
page looks like it
well it looks like a pretty basic page
so once this page is ready
what I will do is here I copy the
content
and paste it here and above and let's
see what's there in my above few things
will change number one here
this app dots users
well here we have to just use
dot dot
there's an approaches for me
so you have to offer some title too so
after this link are you
awful
title this title I can say
okay
so rest everything is fine
so H4 navigation bar nablings here I
have to offer the links for my page HTML
page so
when I talk about index.html file
foreign okay it won't come so
index or external file so I won't say it
is an active anymore I just remove this
line
plus equal to it it's just an normal
address but about would be active in
this case so
eight
plus equal to
active instead of this
Services contact
because as usual thing but I would not
be having any
Pages anymore
because we are in the same location
that's why and here I say this is a
about this is about page
about Bridge
so that's it
I'll go back and check
out fine
home is active right now about you can
see it as an about page right now about
page is just appeared as it is saying
contents are more or less looks like and
same that is why you are able to see
now just like that
I will just go back and copy the others
now here
have CSS navigation bar
active
it is in contacts or make contact as an
actor
so index location file remain same this
is
contact page
so
that's how it is and it would say about
my other properties which is my
Services let me copy sorry
copy this contact
and here
I'll be activating my
service in this case so
class equal to active I remove it from
here
make it available here this is
surface page navigation index pages
about active here or looks good heading
about okay here I change
service
it is a change to
looks fine
see
okay
service contact about
so for about we need to check where we
need to go
so we have got pages
about dot HTML page is also there
so
all there so we would like to see how
the about page will be activated here so
index.html file also contains an about
so here
when I
refresh
well
call
index.ht Page
talk vocal about
is that about page now
services
so like this it is happening for you
okay so that's how exactly my thing is
so we're all good
and uh
Services contact
well my page is now ready and going
forward we would like to beautify my
Pages by offering the CSS well let's get
started with our CSS file so in my CSS
file I will start with my
common properties
which is margin
I'm saying 0 pixel
followed by adding
I'm making a 0 pixel again
we want box sizing
thus I say border
hyphen box
okay
well going forward this is my standard
settings for all different type of
properties now I want the other
properties to be getting introduced that
is for box body text
Dot
body
iPhone
text
insert is body text I said display
Flex
now what I see where the body text is
available go to my index.html file
politics is available here div plus so
here in my CSS file I can say body text
display Flex I say font family
for family I can give anything
God want
to say it
sensory
these two we are offering it later on
align items
anal item Center
followed by justify content
and making a center
then margin top
250 pixels
these are the properties out there
followed by
okay first let's check what is an effect
here
see it looks better now
if you would like to go into the nav I
already have the snap with me
never
display
s then justify content
space around
followed by align item
align items I want to make Center
and then we want to say mid height
so we say when hyphen
okay so midnight we are giving a3h
followed by background color
same color
and same font family we just copy this
form currently and make it available
here well let's check
looks awesome but I still feel the links
needs to be justified we want to make it
even more better but before that I offer
the nav links so here
I say
nav links so dot nav
hyphen lens
this nav links will have display
Flex
display
s and then justify content
that I want to make it space around
again
followed by width
so
with
so width would be 30 percent
perfect and now the nav link Li Dot
nav links
Li
this
Style
no
let's see how it is changing
there we go that it looks really nice so
nablings are ready and I want to make it
a heading heading I want to make it more
organized so let's see about a heading
here I say dot
heading and inside this heading I say
color
which is white
followed by text
transform
text text transform of our case
followed by letter spacing
this letter spacing will be 5 pixels
and followed by last font size
and this font size is just 20 pixel
that's it and let's see how it is
different see
here awesome so this navigation bar is
now looking great and it is giving me
all the basic operation whichever we
have expected now this nav links
whichever we have created okay they are
working fine but I just want to make it
even more beautiful
and how I can make it more beautiful to
make it I would like to go ahead with
the nav links again
Dot
nav links off type anchor tag
now I would like to activate my anchor
type by making it color
White
okay followed by text decoration
text decoration
and followed by letter spacing
let us pressing 3 pixels
and then font weight
font weight Bolt
and font size
14 pixels
and padding
and 16 pixels
both options
that's it and followed by we want to use
the nav licks when I will hover it so
the color should change so we are saying
Dot
nav links and here with li
followed by a DOT
active when the anchor tag is active
then in that case I want to change the
background color
to
lights light signaling I can say
lights
so
we have this option called light C green
that looks beautiful and followed by
saying I copy this
and this active so nav links I like DOT
active background color we are using but
if it is not active then in that case
what you will use
so I can just change the small thing
here
I've changed this color
uh now let me try to copy this first I
tell you about what I want
you copy this and paste it as usual here
what I see is when it is an active
okay well it is an active I will change
the color to
I think this spelling is wrong active it
should be
active background color I want to change
this to Green so for that we are just
using the color hash
this is a green mirror when it is an
active and when this is not active
so we can just say a colon
active which is used now now Ali colon
active or we can say equal whole
equal
over
a colon over and here we say colon not
Dot
act that's it
let's see how it works
awesome this looks beautiful home home
is an active right now let's say it is
on a home page
I can see it is an about page
it is service switch it is a contact now
you can see it looks even more awesome
in this HTML page Hands-On we are
expecting that all of you are aware
about the basic concept of HTML as well
as the CSS so this
kind of learning is going to help you to
understand like how HTML and CSS can
connect together while offering you a
mini application the first application
on this track we're going to offer you
that is related to your HTML
registration page okay so as you know
for this particular registration
development application I would like to
use the visual studio code which is one
of the very very popular tool provided
by Microsoft so this tool we will be
using it for our mini application
development so let's get started with
this so step number one let me go back
and create a new folder now I'm going to
create a new folder name called
registration
and inside this I would require two
files number one is called index dot
HTML
and another one that is called
CSS we can say app dot CSS
so in index.html file we want some
standard development so I want to start
with my HTML tag
so
I already have this HTML based autofill
code provided by your Visual Studio code
so there are plugins are available
inside this so that you can
automatically create the basic structure
for this HTML which you can have the
HTML tag head tag as well as the body
tag and from this point onwards we will
start developing our code now so I want
to develop a registration page so in
this registration page I will start from
my form tag now so inside this form it
is saying like form action to something
I really do not have any backend so I
just leave it as a blank and here I will
start with my H1 tag where I want to say
register
after this register I want to offer the
paragraph tag
where I can say please
spell
for
two
register with us
register okay
okay now after that I would like to
start with horizontal row so HR
so
starting with my horizontal row
and post this because see we would like
to organize our application and now
level in this level for I just want to
give the name called FF it's just the
name and after this FN stands for the
first name and within this label I would
like to use a b type which is a I would
say the Bold here I will pass fasting
bolt attack is close it's a label
inside this level I would like to use
input tag here I will call input app
equal to text and offer few other
details also like I say a placeholder
please order will offer you what to be
free I'm saying first name
that is
the placeholder value after this name
equal to FN that is the stand for first
name after that id id is optional but if
you want to pass we'll use this idfn
at equal to f n and required
because I want this field cannot be
blank
so this is my
first text box where I have this first
name with me
like that I will go ahead and talk about
my next property called password and for
password also I would like to have the
similar details with me
so this level I'll copy
and paste it below
and this is for
your password so we give the name called
PSW
here we are saying password
okay
and input available text so here I will
change input tab equal to password
because password field details would not
be visible to you please here say
placeholder I can say enter
password name equal to you can give PSW
ID equal to we can give same BSW
so we have a whole password in a similar
like we would like to offer a confirm
password fields too I will copy this
line
and paste it again and here we can say
confirm password
you can see
CPU
again password enter
confirm password cpsw
and cpsw
now it's over after this we want to make
it as a horizontal row
closed
and once it is run then we'd like to
have the button with this
so here's the button we can say register
and here in my button I would like to
offer the type equal to submit
yeah
are we going to submit so that's it so
this is the simplest form I have it now
I would like to see how it really looks
like it so from here I would like to
open it regulate finder
let's open this
but it looks like that
fine so this is what my formula form is
ready and now we would like to go back
and start developing my CSS in which I
will beautify my form to offer some more
details on this
well friends as we know the HTML page is
ready it's time to go back and start
developing a CSS to beautify my HTML so
inside the CSS I would like to start
with the tag which is the called body
and inside this body tag I can offer
some basic setups but
I just want to give the basic background
color now which is called
background hyphen color
I can just give the name for tea
rest of the things I can just leave it
as it is now for all the other
properties I can say box sizing
foreign
box
after that
dot container
container
and in this container we have to offer
certain benefits now first thing you
need to understand which are the places
I will be using the container so you see
here in my index.html file
when we talk about form actions in and
all okay we say H1 register we haven't
used any container right now so let's
get added the container
do
class equal to
container
okay and this particular Dev tag will
get closed only at the last
so the strip tag
you close at the last
here so I want to make the look and feed
for this complete container
in much more better ways so here in my
container we want to see
margin Auto
let's press enter here
merging
Auto now with
50 percent
then adding
16 pixel
followed by background color
which we want white
then box shadow
this box Shadow we want to give some all
four Originals 20 pixel
continuation to same 20 pixel
and zero pixel and which color we want
so I just say RGB here
this RGB just give the value called 0
again 0
and the value which you're going to give
to this Alpha because it is always
between 0 to 1 we are saying 0.7 that is
an opacity
well four properties as given now let's
see how it looks
yeah why because we haven't added a CSS
in my HTML so let's add the CSS solve
inside my
browser HTML
now inside my head let me add link
I really call the style sheet href equal
to
app dots uses
that's it
now let's see
there we go looks better now so this is
your container okay which you can see it
is having some Shadow I would like to
organize this all set of text boxes in
much more better way
so after this we want to offer the other
properties to like it for my input
go back to my app CSS
so after this container we want input
input again
time equal to
text
now also
to
input
type
equal to
password
here we offer few things number one bit
which is hundred percent
after
sorry
then padding
one second 15 pixels
then margin
you're nothing five pixels
zero
22 pixel
followed by display
I will say inline block
inline block solid type order do you
want any border
so I say none
in background
we can offer the color so we can say
right smoke
that's it let's see in my HTML
awesome so this looks more beautiful
more organized so this is
your form but I want to make it even
more better now because I want to
perform the validation and in validation
we want to check how the focus will come
in so the beautification needs to be
added more here we want to offer the
same input type text input type password
I copy this
here
now here we want to offer background
color
we want to open the background color on
Focus
this has to be your focus
focus and here also on Focus
now background color we want to change
to anything but other typing we can just
give
same and outline
no
okay so this is my for focus and for the
registration button
so here we say dot
I do not have that class called register
button so I have to create this class
inside my
button
I would like to offer the properties for
those like background color
t
followed by color
which is
White
then padding
we offer 16 pixel
then border
no
the cursor
I think it is better to have pointer
only
than width
100 percent
solved by margin
this Auto
then opacity
and I say 0.8
fine so this is for my registration
version
let's see
wow this looks better now so this is a
full size button
so this is for my button and I want the
moment to take my cursor on button
the color should change or it should
look like an hover
copy this
over
and here we say opacity
I just pick the value for one that's it
now you see now the color is changing
great so like this you see how the
conditions are working on a press on
register you see the messages
please fill the field blank and it is
changing the
when we talk about the situation call
Focus so in this it works like that when
I give the name you see now how the
background color is changing now so it
is a little bit more grayish color so